just imagine being forced out of your
job and chucked out of your home on the
same day
the life of a prime minister is full of
twists turns and turbulence but it's
always toughest at the end i do not
think it would be right for me to try to
be the captain that steers our country
to its next destination
after all most political careers end in
failure
i do so with no ill will
but with enormous and enduring gratitude
to have had the opportunity
to serve the country i love
so what do you do after you've held the
country's top job
which perks do you keep and which do you
lose
[Music]
the biggest perk to be given up is
perhaps the home itself a spacious four
bedroom flat above number 11 downing
street central london location period
features 24-hour security and use of a
large garden perfect for entertaining
[Music]
ex-prime ministers also forgo use of
checkers a luxurious official country
residence in buckinghamshire
and the raf voyager a plane used by the
royal family and senior ministers is
also off limits as for larry the cat
well he's not moving anywhere
some silver linings that come with the
pressure of being prime minister do last
a lifetime
all former pms get to keep their armed
close protection teams which not
and available intended to help former
pms continue to play a part in public
life
they are also entitled to stay at
british embassies and capital cities
across the globe but only if visits
support uk government objectives
some prime ministers are creatures of
the commons and stay on as mps ted heath
stuck around for another 27 years
ladies and gentlemen
we're leaving downing street for the
last time
margaret thatcher made a tearful exit
from downing street after 11 and a half
years as pm
she soon swapped the green benches for
the red ones taking her seat as baroness
thatcher in the house of lords
she also set up a foundation advised the
tobacco company philip morris and wrote
three books when the curtain falls
it's time to get off the stage
and that is what i propose to do john
major's instinct after losing the 1997
election was to head to the oval
after that i hope
that norma and i will be able with the
children to get to
the oval in time for lunch and for some
cricket this afternoon
he took on a series of corporate roles
turned down a peerage and was also
appointed a special guardian to princes
william and harry helping with their
legal affairs after the death of their
mother princess diana in 2007 tony blair
left number 10 and left parliament on
the same day i've uh i've come back here
to search field to my constituency
where my political journey
began and where it's fitting that it
should end
he became middle east envoy for the
quartet the grouping of the united
nations united states european union and
russia now sir tony blair he advised
foreign governments and major companies
reportedly earning tens of millions of
pounds wrote his autobiography writing
my memoir a journey has been a
fascinating and enjoyable experience
responded to the chilcot inquiry into
the 2003 invasion of iraq and
unsuccessfully campaigned against brexit
they've literally created this issue of
brexit as if it's the answer to the
country's problems when it's literally
the answer to nothing his successor
gordon brown took a different approach
and as i leave the second most important
job i could ever hold
i cherish even more the first as a
husband and father
thank you
and goodbye
leaving number 10 with his wife and two
sons he moved back to scotland played a
key role in the 2014 scottish
independence referendum
became un's special envoy for global
education
and gave much of his earnings from books
and speeches to charity
david cameron's departure in 2016 was
sudden soon after he lost the eu
referendum a shock result
i will do everything i can as prime
minister to steady the ship over the
coming weeks and months
but i do not think it would be right for
me to try to be the captain that steers
our country to its next destination
i mean i said of course it's a sad night
for me because i didn't want to be in
this position i wanted britain to stay
in a reformed european union he became
president of alzheimer's research uk and
took on various corporate jobs his work
with one of them the scandal hit
financial services company green sill
capital damaged his reputation mr
cameron lobbied the government on the
firm's behalf before it collapsed
i will shortly leave the job that it has
been the honor of my life to hold
theresa may had a painful departure from
power in the midst of the brexit
deadlock the second female prime
minister but certainly not the last but
she followed john major's example and
the next day was spotted watching the
cricket at lord's
she has stayed in parliament
occasionally making spiky interventions
and debates
why then is the new national security
adviser a political appointee with no
proven expertise in national security
mrs may has a lucrative sideline in
corporate speeches earning between 38
000 and 136
000 pounds a pop and she's said to have
an eye on another big job secretary
general of nato a role yet to be held by
a woman
the only official engagement when all
former prime ministers gather together
is remembrance sunday
when they meet alongside the royal
family at the cenotaph to commemorate
service men and women who have lost
their lives in wars and
conflicts when boris johnson's
premiership comes to an end his wife
carrie and their two children wilfred
and romy will move out of their newly
and expensively refurbished downing
street flat
mr johnson will lose almost half of his
161
401 pound salary
he will keep the 81 932 pounds he
receives as mp for uxbridge and west
rice slip
unless of course he decides to stand
down from parliament
but what might he do next
the international speaking circuit is a
sure-fire way for former world leaders
to cash in yesterday i went
as as we all must
to peppa pig world in the past mr
johnson has earned big writing columns
for the daily telegraph and authoring
books he was supposed to be writing one
about william shakespeare its
publication has been repeatedly delayed
but the most painful adjustment of all
is surely losing the power from being
here at the heart of the action making
massive decisions meeting world leaders
to life away from government with far
fewer commitments where the phone
doesn't ring quite as much and also
knowing whatever the next challenge
nothing will compete with this